durchnässt krank und entkräftet der
fünfjährige lies und sein größerer
bruder geistigen mit ihren eltern sechs
tage im grenzgebiet zwischen belarus und
polen umher
die familie aus syrien wurde von
polnischen und russischen soldaten hin
und her getrieben
die bälle russischen soldaten haben uns
gesagt entweder sterben oder polen
dann haben wir die polnische armee um
hilfe gebeten ob die grenze zu
überqueren bei die kinder hungrig und
krank waren
aber sie haben uns nicht geholfen
sondern zurückgeschickt in der nacht uns
angeschrien und geschlagen
polnische aktivisten hatten die familie
im wald gefunden und hilfe angefordert
anna erzählt sie seien mit dem flugzeug
nach mainz geflogen wie tausend andere
migranten aus syrien irak afghanistan in
diesen wochen auch
irgendjemand hat uns mit dem auto an die
grenzregion gebracht und gesagt er soll
zu den belarussischen soldaten gehen
dort haben sie uns auf einen lkw geladen
und zur polnischen grenze gefahren und
dort haben die soldaten uns gesagt wir
sollen den stacheldraht zerschneiden und
die grenze überqueren
die meisten migranten stranden in der 3
kilometer breiten sperrzone die polen
errichtet hat keine hilfsorganisation
keine medien dürfen dort rein nur das
militär und anwohner was ich dort für
eine tragödie ab spielt das lässt sich
nur erahnen
auf der anderen seite lukaschenkos
machtapparat der weißrussische
machtinhaber nutzt migranten als
druckmittel herr lukaschenko auf einem
rachefeldzug gegen die eu er will sich
mit dem druck den er durch politische
maßnahmen durch die flüchtlinge auf
nachbarstaaten ausübt für die sanktionen
der eu rechnen er will zeigen dass er
macht ausüben kann
kristin deutsch polnische grenze
vergangene woche 35 menschen
eingepfercht in einen kleintransporter
richard klug war zufällig da und hat
gefehlt noch immer halten die schreie
der flüchtlinge in seinen ohren wasser
wasser
sie waren eingepfercht in einem auto im
laderaum dass ein boden luft mit
verschlossenen türen ein glück dass es
nicht heiß waren werden sie in so einer
hitze gefahren hatten dass einige von
ihnen nicht überlebt
[Musik]
laut bundespolizei sind seit anfang
august
6500 menschen aufgegriffen worden
sie kamen belarus und polen nach
deutschland
wenn es nicht gelingt deine antwort
strategie der humanen kontrolle die
gleichzeitig verpressung von lukaschenko
etwas entgegensetzt zu finden dann wird
das ein tödlicher winter dann werden an
der grenze auf europäischen boden
menschen erfrieren denn lukaschenko hat
keine skrupel und das bedeutet auch für
die nächste deutsche regierung dass alle
versprechen die menschenwürde ja nur
wenige stunden von der deutschen grenze
entfernt an der eu außengrenze zu wahren
dass diese versprechen sich als als leer
und enthüllen werden die bilder erinnern
an den beginn der flüchtlingskrise von
2015 sie platzen mitten in die
koalitionsverhandlungen
was wollen spd grüne und fdp in der
migrationspolitik ganz konkret anders
machen im sondierungs papier ist die
rede von schnelleren asylverfahren
migration müsse besser geordnet werden
wir müssen insbesondere auch
verwaltungsgerichte hinreichend
ausstatten damit die asylverfahren lager
fahren schnell durchgeführt werden
können wenn man verfahren beschleunigen
will gibt es zwei möglichkeiten einmal
verfahrens gängig zu vereinfachen oder
eben mehr personal einzustellen
mehrkanal heißt dann endlich auch immer
dass man über die finanzierung des
personals reden muss wir brauchen eine
gemeinsame europäische antwort auf die
illegalen schleuse aktivitäten
lukaschenkos und dafür braucht es
unserer meinung nach hits geordnete
verfahren also dass wir unterstützung
geben bei der aufnahme bei der
registrierung und dann wahrscheinlich
mit einigen mitgliedstaaten die
flüchtlinge dann auch verteilen auf die
europäische union die handlungsfähigkeit
wäre auch ein zeichen an lukaschenko
dass wir uns nicht erpressen lassen
zurück nach der sperrzone zwischen
belarus und polen lies und geist die
beiden syrischen jungen müssen nach
knapp einer woche oder sie ins
krankenhaus nach
nächten in wald und gewalttätigen
soldaten hat mutter aller angst angst
wieder nach belarus abtransportiert zu
werden sie will sich auf keinen fall von
ihren kindern trennen
die angst ist berechtigt sagt christel
von neuen von ärzte ohne grenzen
sie war dabei die polnische soldaten
menschen mitgenommen haben 13 migranten
darunter vier kinder suchten
internationalen schutz bei einer
polnischen hilfsorganisation doch dann
die polnischen grenzsoldaten km schwer
bewaffnet an und nahmen alle
schutzsuchenden mit sie brachten sie weg
wir fuhren an den ort von denen wir
wussten dass es der einzige ort in der
gegend ist an den menschen abgefertigt
werden bevor sie in internierungslager
gebracht werden aber dort waren sie
nicht ein paar stunden später sagten sie
uns mit dem handy ihren standort die
bahn zurück in belarus
pusch becks in polen sind sie an der
tagesordnung obwohl sie nach eu und
völkerrecht rechtswidrig sind heute
wurden sie in polen per gesetz erlaubt
es ist sicherlich keine leichte aufgabe
aber es geht darum dass auf dem recht
auf dem papier jetzt gerade europa recht
einzuhalten ist und sie erwarten von der
bundesregierung aber auch von den
koalitionsverhandlungen dass solche
menschenrechtsverletzungen zunächst
erstmal wirklich deutlich verurteilt
werden aber auch in zukunft unterbunden
werden
frontal will wissen wie die künftige
ampelkoalition solche putsch becks in
polen stoppen will wir als grüne wollen
dass die gelder die diese länder
bekommen für ihre arbeit an den grenzen
gestoppt wird wenn sie eben illegale
buschbeck durchführen auch übrigens für
ausrüstung die sie dafür benutzen und
das ist eben die ebenfalls auch
juristische verfahren gegen die
betroffenen personen braucht um wirklich
hier wieder auf dem grund der
rechtsstaatlichkeit in europäische union
zurück zu kommen und dass wir uns nicht
auch noch daran beteiligen buschbeck
sind völkerrechtlich ein unrechtmäßiges
mittel man muss hier deutlich machen
dass wir schon gut erreicht hat und hier
ein asylantrag stellt dann auch die
chance hat dass diese asylantrag
bearbeitet wird die spd wollte sich zu
fragen von frontal nicht äußern im
sondierungs papier der ampel koalition
steht man wolle das leid und sterben an
den außengrenzen beenden die frage ist
ob diese ziele auch umgesetzt werden
wird deutschland wird die deutsche
regierung sich dafür einsetzen dass es
wirkliche untersuchungen und sanktionen
gibt wenn staaten eu recht brechen ist
die regierung dazu bereit wenn nicht
dann fürchte ich dass auch die
ampelkoalition mit all ihren versprechen
und hoffnungen und ernsthaften absichten
am ende scheitern wird
zurück in polen die syrische mutter anna
und ihre kinder können aufatmen
sie sind am krankenhaus angekommen hier
werden lies und geis untersucht und
versorgt für sie hat die gefährliche
route ein glückliches ende genommen sie
sind in sicherheit vorerst